und jetzt ist mir bild reporter jörg
völkerling zugeschaltet durch dass für
uns an dem ort wo die kleine inga damals
verschwand vor fünf jahren beschreibt
uns doch bitte mal die atmosphäre vor
ort
schaurig schön würde ich die atmosphäre
umschreiben es ist ein riesiger
fichtenwald eine anderthalb kilometer
lange zufahrtsstraße total einsamen die
durch dieses waldgebiet führt heute
morgen als wir da hinein gefahren sind
war ein einziger radfahrer dort
unterwegs dann öffnet sich der wald
irgendwann und einer kleinen lichtung
taucht dann dieser wilhelms hof auf
das sind ist ein ensemble von 45
gebäuden wo suchtkranke menschen leben
und wo auch die familie von inga damals
ein mitarbeiter kannte mit dem man
einfach grillen wollte es ist total
friedlich im moment ist hat sich seit
fünf jahren dort nicht wesentlich viel
verändert fertigrasen man sieht
rindermann sieht esel dämonen wächst auf
der wiese und gleichzeitig fragt man
sich bei jedem schritt in den wald in
denen unüberschaubaren wald und die
waldgebiete ein kleiner stofffetzen auf
dem boden und man denkt sofort könnte
das noch was mit dem alten fall zu tun
haben
gibt es denn parallelen zum fall maddie
und inga und wenn ja welche ja ich habe
mir heute noch mal auch die
berichterstattung von bild angeguckt und
wir hatten erst am 30
mai 2015 wenige tage nach dem
verschwinden von ihnen gehalten wie
geschrieben dieser fall inga ähnelt
immer mehr dem fall mittel in mir kennen
ist einfach ja so frappierend wenn man
bedenkt ein kind verschwindet wird
einfach aus der zeit gerissen und ohne
jede spur zurückzulassen auch verdient
fand man ja nicht mal ein haar überhaupt
nichts und es ist insofern frappierend
weil man jetzt heute weiß dass der
tatverdächtige christian b der also 2007
in unmittelbaren zusammenhang mit den
mccanns verschwinden in praia da luz
waren kurz danach portugal verlassen hat
fast fluchtartig unter seltsamen
umständen kaufte 2010 ein großes anwesen
eine ehemalige kistenfabrik in
neuwegersleben in sachsen anhalt in der
börde das ist ungefähr 90 kilometer von
wilhelms hof entfernt
und was das ganze so auffällig macht
dokumentiert ist ein parkplatzrempler
von christian b an der a2 bei helmstedt
das liegt also quasi genau die autobahn
zwischen braunschweig wo er sein
lebensmittelpunkt hatte und berlin
und das ist nur einen tag gewesen bevor
er verschwand und medien berichten heute
der spiegel berichtet heute dass
christian b auch ein mitarbeiter des
diakoniewerks wilhelms hof persönlich
gekannt haben soll dazu kommt man hat
2015 2016 einen stick mit
kinderpornografischen bildern nackter
kinder nackter mädchen bei ihm gefunden
auf seinem gelände und offenbar auch
kinderkleidung mädchen kleidung die
eltern von inga gehen anders als die
eltern der kleinen maddie nicht so gern
in die öffentlichkeit hast du
informationen für uns wie sie jetzt mit
diesen neuen erkenntnissen umgehen
ja das waren sicherlich ein unterschied
zum fall mittelmeer kennen wo die eltern
sicher sofort massiv an die
öffentlichkeit gewendet haben wodurch
dieser fall auch so viel aufmerksamkeit
erfuhr inga war auch gleich im fokus wie
immer wenn ein kind verschwindet die
polizei viel manpower auch investiert
die eltern haben aber nur bisher ein
einziges mal das war 2017 dem stern ein
interview gegeben
sie lassen jetzt nur noch ihre anwälte
sprechen die natürlich sagen dass die
eltern auch durchaus vorwürfe haben
fragen an die ermittler weil sie glauben
dass die suche nach inga einfach viel zu
früh aufgegeben worden ist die eltern
sind inzwischen getrennt sie gehen ganz
unterschiedlich auch mit dem
verschwinden ihrer tochter um während
die mutter victoria sich einfach immer
noch an den gedanken klammer dass ihre
tochter noch lebt und sie sie irgendwann
wieder in ihre arme schließen kann hat
der vater jens uwe keinerlei hoffnung
weil er bis heute keinen kein anzeichen
kein lebenszeichen von seiner tochter
bekommen hat dankeschön jack werke lenkt
wieder informationen